RAY WANG: Hello, everyone.
We're going to spend
some time talking
about how to lead a data-driven
digital transformation.
And this is what every
leader should know.
I'm Ray Wang with
Constellation Research.
And I want to start
with this fact.
61% of the Fortune
500 have been gone.
They've been merged, acquired,
gone bankrupt since 2000.
Think about that.
That is the pace of change that
has been happening since 2000.
These are business models.
These are organizations
transforming,
and in the process, taking
out the competitors.
I want you to take some
time and follow along.
What do you think is the hottest
performing stock since 2000?
I going to put
some names up here.
You can guess, yell out loud,
tell me what you're hearing.
All right, the FANGs, I'll
throw another one just for fun.
Are you ready?
I'm going to do the countdown,
5, 4, 3, 2, are you ready?
Here it is.
Domino's Pizza, that is the
number one top-performing stock
since 2010.
Now
This is an incredible
story of transformation.
Domino's actually won the
battle for transformation.
Think about it.
How often do you
order a pizza a week?
And when you order that pizza,
think about it, what happens?
You're on the app.
And at 4:00 PM, suddenly a
notification shows up and says,
would you like a pizza?
And most people say yes.
Now, behind the back-end
of what is happening
is a mile of data
transformation,
a mile of data that's
actually happening,
and a massive digital
transformation effort.
Once you order that
pizza, it sets off
everything, inventory,
supply chains.
It sets off the kitchen.
The kitchen knows that they've
got to get this pizza in
and delivered by
30 minutes or less.
And you get a status.
You know that the pizza
order has been taken.
You know the pizza
is in the oven.
is 10 minutes away,
five minutes away, and two
minutes away from your door.
And in fact, you never
had the pull out any cash.
You can pay
everything on the app.
That is what we're
talking about.
And in fact, if
you even try, you
can actually take a
picture of the pizza.
It goes into an AMIL
engine, and they
test the quality of that pizza.
That is what we're talking
about as a major transformation
occurs.
Now, we can say Domino's won
the digital transformation war,
but did it really win?
And actually, there's
something that's actually
happening, because we
are seeing that this
is the foundation of every
single digital business,
the ability to bring data, the
ability to bring these inputs,
be able to put all this
signal intelligence in play.
And the goal here, it's about
getting to precision decisions.
That decision velocity becomes
a very important piece.
Now why are precision
decisions so hard?
How do we get there?
How do we become successful?
Well, there's a
reason these are hard.
It's really because we've
got so many data sources.
There's data all over the place.
It's sitting in a mainframe.
It's sitting over on an app.
It's in an IoT device.
It's sitting on
three other clouds.
And that makes it very hard.
Now, that also bring
us to the point
that we have complex
data environments.
These environments are crazy.
And there's also
all these privacy
rules, and requirements,
and data residency.
And suddenly, data is encrypted,
some data is not encrypted.
We've got to pull
all this together.
And then, of course, there's a
lot of external data sources,
too.
We're not just talking about the
stuff that's in your control.
We're talking about
weather feeds.
We're talking
about social media.
We're talking about
videos from other places.
We're talking about chats.
And this has to come together.
And then, of course, we
also have the slow process
of getting stuff into
a data warehouse,
getting into the data.
And this is not easy to do,
bring all this data together.
And then it gets even worse.
The speed that's
required, the speed--
you want to make a
decision right away.
If you're doing a
credit check right now,
you're not going
to wait 10 minutes.
If someone's
defrauding your ATM,
you're not going to
wait five minutes.
You want to know that
something is happening.
And so we've got to
bring all this together,
and we've got to
do it very quickly
to get to that
precision decision.
Now, there is a lot of change
that's going on with data.
We have to understand that
this data, there's a lot of it.
I'm not going to
read all the stats.
You can follow along.
But the most important one,
for me, is really the last one.
70% of your mission
critical data
is not even in your four walls.
It's coming from
external sources.
And we've got to
[INAUDIBLE] that data.
We've got to manage that data.
In some cases, you're going
to transform that data,
secure it, and deliver it.
And it is a pain.
It is not easy to do.
And so we have this
insight supply chain
that starts with all the
upstream data sources.
Everything comes
in, and then we've
got to bring this stuff in.
We've got to figure
out what is going on.
So let's classify that data.
Let's transform it so it fits in
there to what we want it to do.
And we've got to go augment
and add different tags,
add different sources, add
different metadata on top
of it.
And then when we master
it, secure that data,
then we've got to figure
out who to deliver it to.
Where does it go?
Is it an external source?
Is it active?
Is it inactive?
Do we take it out of the system?
And then, of course, we have to
figure out how to refresh that.
And that cycle goes
on and on, every time.
So once we nurture
that, then we can
start thinking
about how we can get
to the data-to-decisions
lifecycle.
This is extremely
important, how we
take data, all types of data,
structured, unstructured,
semi-structured.
And then when we align
that to a business process,
It becomes powerful.
Order to cash, campaign
to lead, hire to retire,
incident to resolution,
procure to pay.
And you notice
there's a line there?
That line shows you what
the tech team is doing.
The top part is what the
business side wants to do.
I want to take those
patterns, and I
want to figure out
what is the insight.
And I want to
understand that insight.
And when I understand insight,
then I want to take that,
and I want to take action
and make decisions.
Sometimes making no
decision is a decision.
But if you look at this,
it becomes a cycle.
We then take that, and come
back over and over again.
Now, we're doing these things
today, in many cases, in batch.
It's taking forever, and
we've got to make decisions
in milliseconds.
Yeah, decisions in
milliseconds, and this
is why decision
velocity is important
getting to precision decisions.
Now one of the ways
to get there is
when we apply machine
learning and automation.
And we've got to
answer that question
is, when do we automate things?
And we've got seven tests on
when automation makes sense
and when you apply
human-powered approaches.
So when things are
highly repetitive,
that's something you don't
want to have humans do.
What do we do?
We get tired.
We make mistakes.
We get a little bit lazy.
We get sloppy, because we're
doing it over and over again.
We are totally bored.
And that's where
you want to play
something that's AI-powered.
When we think about what
actually happens with lots
of volume, we're overwhelmed.
We can't possibly do
all that on our own.
And that's another area
where we go to automation.
And then, of course, when the
time to completion is quick,
well, humans don't
scale very well.
When there's lots
of interaction,
humans, once again, get
overwhelmed and confused.
There's so much happening.
I can probably maybe
happen one, two,
maybe three things
at once, and that's
really pushing the limits.
But when you're interacting
with all these devices, all
these connections, and have to
make those decisions quickly,
that's where the power
of automation comes in.
However, things
that are complex,
they cannot be
[INAUDIBLE] by math,
that's what we actually
see humans play a role.
And we start to learn.
We apply humans and machines,
and we bring them together.
When things are
very creative that
requires to think outside
of the box, we're humans.
We make the rules,
and we are really
good at breaking the rules.
And once that's
in place, we also
think about fine motor skills.
And that's another area where
automation doesn't always
do a great job.
But these are important
things, because we
have four important questions.
These are the most
important questions
you have to answer as we
enter this autonomous decade.
One, when do you trust
intelligent machine automation,
completely let go, let it
all happen with the machine?
When do we augment the
machine with a human,
because we want to
understand the nuance?
We want to understand why
something isn't working, when
do you make those
exceptions, because 99.99%
accuracy in medicine
might not even be enough.
We might actually have to get
it down to the point it's eight
9's.
And that's going to be
interesting in an eight-sigma
quality situation.
And then the third
question we ask
is how do we augment the
human with the machine
so humans can make
quicker decisions,
we can make the suggestions, we
can make the recommendations?
And then, in what
processes do you always
trust human judgment?
These are the
questions we're going
to play to apply to every
single business process
as we think about
that transformation.
Now, why do you want to do this?
We don't do artificial
intelligence and AI just
for fun.
We do it because we have
outcomes we want achieve.
First, tell me what's going on.
What is that perception?
Then, give me a notification.
Give me an alert when something
happens, because that's
way too much information.
I can't see everything at once.
So let's filter down to
the important things.
And then after that, help
me make a recommendation.
You've seen what
I've done before.
Make a suggestion.
And every time I reply
to that suggestion,
I have a digital feedback
loop, why I chose something
and where that goes.
And you have the attribution.
You've got context on when,
where, why what process
I was in, who I was with.
And that helps us to learn.
And over time, I want you to
automate those recommendations.
And then after a while,
all that information
builds on each other,
and we can start
making predictions,
and forecasts,
and understanding
what might happen.
And then we get to one of
the most important things
you can possibly do.
It is about mitigating risk.
Prevention is so important.
Now, let me explain.
When we look back
there used to be--
I mean, if you imagine,
you have a massive recall,
a massive recall.
So one manufacturer
had a massive recall.
It was like 150 phones took out
$8 billion over eight weeks.
That's crazy.
Now, if we could apply
machine learning,
artificial intelligence
to drive down the ability
to triangulate a problem, we
could take it from eight weeks
to one week.
And that would be a
billion-dollar recall.
To go from one week to one day
would be $100 million recall.
What's a million dollars
to solve that problem,
to save $100 million
and even $8 billion?
And that's where you
see the power of AI,
really, in helping
you mitigate the risk,
figure out compliance.
One fine in GDPR could cost
you 3% of your revenues,
not profits, your revenues.
And then we start to see
some of the benefits that
are out there.
Now, what else is happening?
Well, we've got a
couple of things we have
to do to be able to get there.
We have to figure out how do we
outpace the speed of business?
This is important.
The pace of change is
happening so quickly,
we need ways to catch up.
We need ways to get
to that automation
for that transformation
to occur.
The other pieces we
want to work faster,
but we can't do
that in human scale.
And how do we deliver
that in human scale?
It's going to take some time.
And so we've got to figure
out when we automate
and augment our
manual processes.
That's an important piece.
We asked those four
questions earlier.
And the reason we have
to do that is there's
some processes that will
never be automated, that have
to have a human intervention.
But there's so many processes
that we have to think about
before we can bring that
automation to achieve that data
transformation.
And then, the other
piece that's important
is the scenarios that
happen, they're complex.
They're complex
business scenarios
that require some thought,
in terms of both the business
models and the monetization
models that are behind it.
And then, of course, we
have to figure out how
to get to the next best action.
How many of you
remember these books,
Choose Your Own Adventure?
One of my favorites.
Well, what is that
next best action?
How do you make that choice?
How do you get there
to be successful?
And then, of course, one of
the things that we can deliver
is mass personalization
at scale.
That's not something
we can do manually.
That's something we want
to be able to deliver,
in terms of figuring out
personalization, getting
the preferences, getting all
the context that's required,
figuring out the restrictions.
Maybe you have a food allergy.
You can't eat peanuts.
You can't eat milk.
Maybe you don't have
certain types of meats
that you are religiously
unable to consume.
And so we want to be able to
capture that and bring that
to life.
And then, of course, there
are a other things we can do.
We can do dynamic pricing
and pricing optimization,
taking networks, and
understanding demand signals,
supply signals.
Using that to
figure out if we're
efficiently pricing
our offerings,
and putting that into work.
And then, of course, regulatory
compliance is a big issue.
Where can we actually make sure
we meet what we need to do?
If you're in
highly-regulated industries,
this is very
important because you
don't want your best
people figuring out
regulatory compliance.
That's an area
where you want to do
massive amounts of automation,
massive amounts of software
scale, and where you
can as being preventive
about that on the AI side.
And then we talked
about mitigating risk.
If we can actually mitigate
the risk of a bankruptcy, risk
of a bad filing, risk of
actually doing something that
takes down billions of
dollars of your company
or even hundreds of
dollars of your company,
that's a very important
piece in figuring out how
to actually get that to scale.
So how do we get there?
How do we become successful?
Well, we've got to figure
out how to get the speed.
Speed is so important.
How do we actually
make decisions quicker?
There's a concept that we
call decision velocity.
And I've been talking about it.
Decision velocity is the ability
to get to the faster decisions
you can make, the
more likely you're
going to succeed, and even
beat, the competition.
I'll give you an example.
Today, bots can actually operate
at a 100 decisions per second.
Humans, at best, can
respond in, maybe, an hour,
but we have to go through
the organizational structure.
And that might even take a
day to get to a decision.
So if folks are making hundreds
of decisions in seconds,
and humans are only making a
decision, maybe, a half day,
we've got a problem.
And imagine, if that's
your competitors that
are putting automation and AI to
work, you are already, at least
exponentially, behind.
So speed becomes a role.
Ease of use is also
super important.
Our ability to actually
access that information,
see it, visualize it,
utilize it in a way
so that we've democratized
that information so people
can quickly make decisions.
That visualization
is so important,
because that ease of use
means that I can pick it up
in any device I'm using.
I can actually do it in any
context of a business process.
And that, actually, helps me
get to that transformation.
And then, of course,
we have to make
sure these are industry
ready and business ready.
The name of a
customer is different
when you're in health care,
because that's a patient.
When you're in legal and
professional services,
that's a client.
And so when we think about
the role of a customer,
it's very, very different.
The language is different.
The industries are different.
The regulations are different.
Now some value chains are
similar to each other.
And they will collapse, and
we can work through them.
So things, comms, media,
entertainment and telco, those
have converged because
you're selling content.
You're using different
networks with distribution.
And the technology
enables that so
that you can deliver
it to every customer.
Now, contextually
relevant is important.
Now you might want to know
why I put the slide up here.
I've always wanted to use
the Easter Island slides.
I have no idea why
these heads are here.
And that's my point on
contextually relevant,
like why?
What's the location?
What's the time?
Where am I?
What business process?
Am I happy?
Am I feeling great?
Did I have a great
experience before?
Contextually relevant
becomes an important area
of the attribute.
And then, of course,
we want these
built with flexible
architecture,
the ability to
actually drag and drop,
the ability use
containers, the ability use
things like
Kubernetes, the ability
to actually take microservices
and bring them together,
that's where it
gets very exciting.
And then, of course,
it has to be secure.
Security is such an important
factor, especially given today
with the DDoS attacks,
the DNI attacks.
All the things that
are actually happening,
we want to make sure that the
data is secure, it's encrypted,
it is available to use.
And then, of course, once
we have all that together,
we can start thinking
about potential use cases.
So let's take a look.
What's going on?
What are some use cases?
Well, the first one
is we want to be
like transform old
industries with new tech.
This is about thinking about
brand-new types of business
models.
I'm going to give
you an example here.
So how many of you
actually fill out
the warranty card for a toaster?
Come on, who fills out the
warranty card for a toaster,
anybody?
Now, usually in a room of like
1,000, maybe 5,000 people,
we might get like two
or three people that
fill the warranty card.
Now, you don't have to
answer that question.
But let me explain
why it's so important.
Imagine the first
phone call that's
made to the manufacturer
of that toaster.
Do people ever call up and
say, oh, I love your toaster,
it is amazing?
No, they don't do that.
That first phone call is
a call about two things.
One, my toaster is broken,
can you help me fix it,
or two, I don't know
how to use something.
Those are typically the problems
that you get on the first call.
Now the interesting challenge
is the toaster manufacturer
does not know who the customer
is on that phone call.
It is a horrible experience,
because for 10 minutes,
that poor rep is
trying to figure out,
where did you get the toaster?
What model is that toaster?
When did you purchase
that toaster?
And sometimes they figure
it's not even their toaster.
So, OK, we get this
kind of situation.
But think about it,
that first phone call--
that toaster's probably $40.
That first phone call
takes about 30 minutes
to diagnose the problem.
You're already at
negative NPS, and you've
churned $5 of the profit, or
maybe even the revenue of that,
and you've completely
destroyed all your profit
on that first phone call,
because your call center
costs are, maybe, $15 an hour.
That is a crazy proposition.
So let me change the proposition
and ask you this question.
If I told you, connect that
toaster to the internet,
and if you do that, we
will make sure we monitor
the health of that toaster,
protect your privacy,
all you have to do is provide
us, maybe, a text number, maybe
an email, whatever
you're comfortable with,
and we will monitor
that toaster.
And if there is a defect,
we'll let you know.
If there is a potential
problem or an upgrade
that he have to tell you
about, we'll let you know, too.
And 90 days before that
toaster is going to die,
we will give you a warning.
Would you take that offer now?
Would you register your toaster?
Now, if you said yes, thank
you, because now I can actually
do a bunch of things.
I can actually create a
whole bunch of opportunities
with that toaster,
because I can say,
hey, I'm remote-monitoring
your toaster,
and there's something bad
that's about to happen.
Would you like to
buy a new toaster?
And you might take the offer.
And I even give you the
offer of the same price
you paid for 10 years ago.
That's a pretty
cool offer, right?
And I might even do
something different.
I might actually
say, look, would you
be interested in getting
this toaster for $0.15
a month for the
next eight years?
We'll give you a
brand-new toaster.
Well, you're thinking,
hey what is that?
Well, that's called
toast as a service.
Why wouldn't you do that?
And pretty soon I can get
to some interesting things.
If you say yes on
the toaster, I might
make you an offer in
other kitchen appliances,
and say, look, I will do
your entire kitchen for $100
a month.
And if any product
ever dies or fails,
we'll get you a brand new one.
We will make sure we monitor
the health of those products.
We'll make sure that
all the safety is there.
And that's all you have
to pay, $100 a month.
What have we done?
We've created five different
business models built on data.
And this is the
digital transformation
we're talking about.
The first one, we're doing
customer experience monitoring.
We're making sure
that the product's OK.
We want to know what's going on.
Now, I have a very
interesting question for you.
Why do bagels cause a lot
of problems in toasters?
And that's really what I
really wanted to ask you.
Why does that happen?
Why are you bagels
cause problems?
And so we can actually
see some very interesting
regional statistics.
You will see that,
maybe, in New York,
the bagels are actually causing
more problems than, perhaps,
in London where you don't
see a lot of bagels.
And that's the type of thing
that we're starting to do.
And then that customer
experience monitoring,
we're trying to figure out what
are the most common problems
that are occurring.
Why do toasters break more in
Houston, Texas than in Dubai?
Think about it.
What could it be,
what could it be?
Humidity.
Something we can actually do
customer experience monitoring,
track down problems,
understand what
customers are experiencing, and
actually improve our products.
The second thing is we can
do remote field service.
Anything that's broken,
remote diagnostics,
we can fix them ahead of
time so that you don't
have to send someone out there.
And you can actually keep
people in a warranty plan.
The third piece, we suddenly
have a services model post,
toast as a service.
Think about it, for $0.15 a
month for the next eight years,
we will take care
of your toaster.
It's a great deal.
We'll get you a replacement.
If anything breaks,
we'll take care of that.
And then, of course,
we have the ability
to go direct to consumer.
That means the
toaster manufacturer
who traditionally sold to
retailer can now go to direct.
They can actually offer
something to them.
And then, of course,
the cross-sell,
we'll do your entire kitchen.
Five business models
off of data, and that's
just a toaster.
That could be an appliance.
That could be your car.
That could be any
manufactured good
where you're actually
providing these capabilities.
This is the power of
the transformation
we're talking about.
The second piece, we've
got to rethink and invent
brand-new types of
business models.
And these could actually
be in a different form.
And let's take the same vein.
Let me make you an offer here.
For $15 a month, I'm
going to give you
85-inch screen TV for seven
years and a free upgrade.
Would you take that?
Would you take that deal?
Now you're like, wait,
what's the catch?
What's going to happen?
why did he do that?
Well, it's actually
a really good deal.
You're spending
less than $1,000,
and you get a free upgrade
for awesome, brand-new TV.
And if you were
to say yes, well,
what would the business be?
The manufacturer of that TV or
someone else in a warranty plan
could provide a very cool offer.
They would go and
figure out, hey,
what products are better, which
one has a [INAUDIBLE] track
record.
They would take
data from a company
like Best Buy and say,
hey, which one breaks more?
Who has got a
better track record?
And then, pretty
soon, they would
be able to make an offer
to you like what we did.
And every manufacturer
can go direct to consumer.
Or a new player could
emerge that says,
I'll take care of
everyone's TVs.
And if they did that, they
would have a brand-new type
of business model.
The manufacturers suddenly
have more information
about which
components break more,
which features are
being used, why
are those features being used,
and of course, what it does.
It allows you the
ability to think
about how to actually take
all your broken defect
and actually apply
that to re-insurance.
And so suddenly, the
manufacturer is the insurer.
The manufacturer
is now insuring,
and they've got the capability
to keep these units in there.
And if you did this for the
next three to five years,
well, you would actually
dominate a market.
And you'd be able to
actually say, look, I'm
going to guarantee you a TV.
It doesn't matter
what the brand is.
It's good for 85 inches.
And we'll take care of you for
$15 a month for seven years.
For seven years, you will
lock every customer down.
That's a pretty good thing.
And you can start
offering other things.
Back to the kitchen, and
maybe I'll do your HVAC unit.
I'll do your air conditioning
and heating for you.
So that's one option.
Now, the other thing is
we're building what we call
data-driven digital networks.
These data-driven
digital networks
are happening everywhere.
It's about going across
different value chains.
It's about converging
industry value chains
and actually getting
something interesting.
So manufacturing,
retail, and distribution
could be one chain.
Health care, insurance,
and public sector
could be one chain.
And we're seeing that collapsing
in different industries.
So what we need to
do to get started?
Well, it's very exciting.
First of all, we've got to start
with answering the business
question.
Ask questions that you
don't have an answer to.
Normally, you would
ask a question
to say, yeah, how is the
number of marketing leads?
What's coming in, or how
is our performance in terms
of revenue per unit sale?
OK, great.
That's interesting.
But when you start
asking questions outside
of departments, it
gets a little tricky.
You're like, right, oh
but I don't have the data.
Well, that's the point.
You want to be about ask
the right business question.
Do I bring in 10 more
FTEs in marketing
or do I spend a million
dollars on a campaign?
Very valid question.
But I don't know
what the answer is.
I don't know how to get there.
Well, that's OK.
Ask the question first, and
then let's go figure out
where to find the data sources.
Once we understand where
the data sources are,
we now have the opportunity to
then do something different.
We can then bring that
information together,
help visualize it differently.
Look at this chart right here.
This heat map, I want to know
why those areas are brown,
don't you?
Or what's deep blue
versus what's light blue?
And what you're
trying to do is help
people ask the right questions,
understand how to use the data,
and understand how
those questions result
in how you actually
organize that data,
and what do you search
for and bring together.
Then what we want to do is
connect it to the right people.
We know the questions.
We know the flow
and the process.
We are building
data proficiency.
Then we've got to go out and
connect it to the right people
so that they can make
the right decisions.
And they surface up those
decisions at the right time.
And once that's in place,
it's got to look all cool.
got to get awesome
visualization.
You've got to be able
to see what's going on.
And when you have that
in place, then you
understand, OK,
now I can actually
use that data he can put
that use to be successful.
OK, so we talked about all this.
We also have to think about
the ethical use of that data,
and of course, in AI.
And we've got five
rules to get you there.
Those five rules are important.
The first one, it's
got to be transparent.
You've got to see
what's going on.
You've got to understand
the algorithms.
You've got to understand why
those algorithms are there.
And then you've got to figure
out if there are biases,
you've got to be
able to explain them.
Now, biases aren't a bad thing.
If you're deliberately
discriminating
against left-handers with
purple hair or not deliberately,
and you've found out that you've
done that, we've got a problem.
But if the bias is
there because you're
selecting for certain things
and certain characteristics
that are really important.
Like for example, you might
have to have military training
to be able to get into
a secure location,
you might to have to have
a certain skill in math,
maybe you have a certain
skill in communications
to be able to get a job,
totally makes sense.
But you've got to be
able to explain it.
And once you can
explain it, if there's
a problem like bias,
which we talked about,
we've got to be able to reverse
it, unlearn something that's
wrong.
And then, of course,
once that's in place,
we've got to be able
to train these systems.
These systems take years.
I told you this earlier.
Imagine, 90% accuracy
in manufacturing,
that's not a problem.
That's probably OK.
But we've got to figure out
what the exceptions are.
90% accuracy in health care?
No way.
90% accuracy in
autonomous driving?
No way.
When there's lives
involved, we're
expecting higher degrees
of quality and precision.
And then once that's in place,
we always have this fear like,
oh my god, the machines
are taking over.
They're going to come attack us.
All right, well, if you're
afraid of that, you,
start every process
with a human,
and you end a process
with a human as a check.
All right, so now you've
got it, five simple rules.
These are design
principles for AI ethics,
something you want to
make sure you apply
as we're talking about it.
OK, so we talked a
lot, 61% of the Fortune
500 merged, acquired,
gone bankrupt since 2000.
Massive amounts of
change are in place.
We have to think about
how we get started.
The first part is we're building
new experiences and outcomes
in this transformation.
So think about what that is.
Apply design.
Thinking, apply a lower
empathy, start with that.
Put yourself in the
customer's shoes.
And then we've got to
figure out how we actually
build a culture of digital.
What's that digital DNA?
Let's make sure folks can
bring right brain, left brain
activities together.
They've got the data
proficiency to be successful.
And then when we
have it in place,
form always follows function.
Form follows function.
Get the business model right and
the monetization model right,
first, and then
we can figure out
which cool technologies apply.
Of course, we're going
to start in the Cloud.
Of course, there's going to
be machine learning and AI.
And then, maybe on the edge,
there's IoT and something else.
Maybe we're using computer
vision, and augmented reality,
and virtual reality, and
putting that all together.
And, of course, form
follows function.
Now once we have
that in place, we've
got to shift from gut-driven
to data-driven decisions.
We're using data
to advance forward.
We're figure out what products--
figure out why
something happens.
And we've got to have
that data in place.
And once we have
that data in place,
we can start figuring out
how to build the patterns,
how to automate.
And then, of course,
applying the AI either.
this isn't easy.
If this was easy you could
just buy it in a package
and be done.
And so a lot of
this transformation
requires you to co-innovate
and co-create with partners.
Remember, we can't do it alone.
You want to co-innovate and
co-create with partners.
And if you put all this
in place, we're ready.
We're ready to do this
data-driven transformation
that's out there for you.
So thank you very much.
If you've got any
questions, please
feel free to reach out to me.
Happy to help you.
Have a great event.